the Joe Rogan experience and it's
describing that there was this thing
with Vox where Carlos Mesa was
minimizing the the impact of an Tifa and
kind of joking around about it and
making it seem like it's just no big
deal and he got really upset to steven
crowder was making fun of the fact that
he's gay and the fact that he talks with
a lisp and that Crowder mentioned that
along with mocking his stance on an Tifa
and then it became this gigantic thing
that steven crowder is a gay basher but
but didn't become a big deal is that
this guy is minimizing violent fascists
and that's what i mean that's how i feel
about this when you're trying to enforce
your own ideology on other people and
you have no tolerance for anybody with a
differing opinion particularly
journalists that is fascism it's so
ironic to call yourself an anti-fascist
when you're literally enforcing your own
particular ideology to the point of
violence and you're wearing masks and
you're running around hitting people and
pretending that you're being inundated
with Nazis and white supremacists and
that this is all necessary like that old
man that was just driving and they're
directing traffic and forcing him to
obey them and then when he doesn't want
to they chase after him and assault him
it's [ __ ] bananas and the fact that
this city has not stepped in and
recognized that they have a real problem
because this has got momentum behind it
and the people that are involved that
are non-violent you gotta speak up
they've got to speak up if you're a
person that really believes that there
shouldn't be homophobia and there
shouldn't be violence and there
shouldn't be white supremacy good for
you you probably got involved in this
for all the right reasons but if you
don't recognize that someone like you
yourself who is a person of a different
ethnicity you're not a white person
you're Vietnamese you're a gay man and
you got assaulted for no reason you
didn't do anything that mean it's almost
like a test of where do your values
truly lie and if you think it's okay for
a person like you to just get assaulted
for no reason you are the problem you're
the problem
your mindset is the problem
it's not whether or not there should be
white supremacy of course there should
be it's not whether or not there
shouldn't be people be able to freely
express themselves of course there
should be that is not what the issue is
what the issue is is group mob mentality
when you get people together and you let
them wear masks and you tell them that
they're fighting against some evil and
then they feel justified and hitting a
person like you it is really sickening
and there's this diffusion of
responsibility thing that happens when
one person hits you and everybody feels
like it's ok to hit you it's a mob
mentality thing and it's it is extremely
common with human beings
I've got been in mob situations it's
terrifying because you feel it in the
air you feel the chaos in the air when
you're in some sort of a large-scale
brawl type situation like anything can
happen people just run up on people and
start punching them it's not like two
people alone in a like an open area
where they can talk and work things out
no it's chaos and there's some weird
animal activity there's some weird weird
animal instinct aspect to it that is
very unique to humans and when you see
something like this and see a guy like
you just getting peppered with
milkshakes and punched in the head and
it's [ __ ] disturbing and for these
people to dismiss that and not stand out
not stand up and say hey this is not
what we're supposed to be about this is
not what I signed up for they become a
part of the problem I'm sure there's
people listening to this that are upset
at this because maybe you but you've
support and Tifa
you support their ideology think about
what you actually support think about
what this is really all about what you
shouldn't be supporting is people
wearing masks running around [ __ ]
hitting people you ain't changing [ __ ]
with that all you're gonna do is call
for more people with masks from the
other side if people feel like
right-wing people are being attacked and
and I don't think you're even right-wing
are you I mean what are you just would
if you had a gun to your head or a mace
to your face what would you we see
you're a centrist what would you say I
think it's fair to describe me as a
center right center right okay which is
fine it should be okay I mean this
should be we should be allowed to have
disagreements of ideologies and of
political persuasions political leanings
but this is it's twisted and it's
twisted the way it's being depicted in
the media it's very strange how it's
being dismissed it's very strange and
that there's really people in 2019
debating whether or not it's okay to
assault journalists it's [ __ ] madness
[Applause]